.
BUT ANYWAY, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TONIGHT.
NOW, WE BEGIN WITH THIS.
ONLY 330 MILES SOUTH OF WHERE WE
ARE SITTING RIGHT NOW, WITH
AMAZING WEATHER, BEAUTIFUL
BEACHES, AND RICH CULTURE,
INTELLIGENT HARDWORKING AMAZING
PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE OF CUBA, THEY
SHOULD BE LIVING IN PARADISE.
INSTEAD, OVER THE LAST FIVE OR
SIX DECADES, WE'VE HAD SELFISH
POWER-HUNGRY DICTATORSHIPS.
THEY HAVE TURNED THE ISLAND INTO
A COMMUNIST HELLHOLE.
IT CONFISCATED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES, FARMS,
BUSINESSES.
THEY NATIONALIZED ALL MAJOR
CORPORATIONS AND MEDIA OUTLETS
OUTLAWED ALL DESCENT.
THE RESTRICTED AIR TRAVEL, AND
YES, THEY MURDERED OR IMPRISONED
ANYONE WITH THE COURAGE TO SPEAK
OUT.
THE CONDITIONS ARE SO BAD THAT
FOR OVER 50 YEARS, THE CUBAN
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FLEEING THE
ISLAND IN DROVES THERE AND LOOK
AT YOUR SCREEN.
LOOK AT THIS PERILOUS JOURNEY.
BROKEN DOWN, DILAPIDATED,
RICKETY BOATS, SHARK INFESTED
WATERS, RISKING THEIR LIVES IN
MAKESHIFT RAFTS AND INNER TUBES
EVEN, AND LITERALLY ANYTHING
THAT WILL FLOAT IN THE HOPE OF
MAKING IT TO THE SHORES OF
AMERICA AND GETTING 1 FOOT ON
DRY LAND.
NOW, TODAY THOUGH STILL LIVING
IN CUBA, THEY FACE THESE DIRE
CONDITIONS.
MANY ARE RISKING THEIR LIVES
THIS VERY NIGHT.
MOST ARE FORCED TO IMAGINE THIS,
LIVE ON LESS THAN A DOLLAR A
DAY.
FOOD IS SCARCE.
WE HAVE THE CUBAN PEOPLE WAITING
IN LINE FOR HOURS FOR A
GOVERNMENT ALLOWANCE.
OH, YOU GET FIVE EGGS A MONTH
PER PERSON AND YOU GET A FEW
POUNDS OF RICE PER MONTH ALONG
WITH 2 KILOGRAMS OF MEAT EVERY
TEN DAYS.
MILK, IT'S ONLY PROVIDED FOR
PREGNANT WOMEN AND CHILDREN
UNDER 7.
I'M NOT MAKING ANY OF THIS UP.
THIS IS COMMUNISM.
THIS IS A MURDERING COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP.
SO, TOOTHPASTE, BASIC MEDICINE,
EVEN ASPIRIN, HARD TO FIND.
BUILDING MATERIALS, EVEN MORE
SCARCE.
CUBA'S ONCE GREAT CITIES ARE NOW
CRUMBLING.
THE ROADS ARE NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
AND THE COWS, I'VE NEVER SEEN SO
MANY 1950 MODEL CARS
SEEMINGLY HELD TOGETHER WITH
SUPERGLUE AND STRING, AND
FRANKLY INGENUITY OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE NO OTHER CHOICES.
BUT BELIEVE IT OR NOT, EVEN IN
CUBA TODAY, THE HORSE AND
CARRIAGE IS STILL A WIDESPREAD
MODE OF TRANSPORTATION, AND MUCH
OF CUBA.
AND AS I POINT OUT IN CHAPTER 4,
MY BOOK THAT I WROTE BEFORE THE
ELECTION COME "LIVE FREE OR
DIE," SOCIALISM AND ITS HISTORY
OF FAILURE.
WHATEVER NAME, WHATEVER
MANIFESTATION, ANYWAY IT'S BEEN
TRIED, THESE PROMISES ARE NEVER
CAPPED.
IT WILL ALWAYS RESULT IN
DISHONESTY, BROKEN UNFULFILLED
PROMISES, MORE POVERTY, NOT LESS
POVERTY.
AND THEN WHEN IT'S ALL SAID AND
DONE, HOW MUCH FREEDOM TO DO
GIVE UP IN THE NAME OF FALSE
PROMISES OF SECURITY?
A CASE IN POINT.
FIDEL CASTRO PROMISED A STATE OF
THE ARTS SOCIALIST UTOPIA, A
WORKER'S PARADISE FREE OF ANY
AND ALL OUTSIDE INFLUENCES.
INSTEAD, HE TURNED THIS ONCE
PROSPEROUS COUNTRY INTO A
DESTITUTE WASTELAND TOTALLY
DEPENDENT ON FOREIGN NATIONS.
CUBA TODAY IMPORTS ALMOST ALL OF
ITS FOOD AND OTHER BASIC
SUPPLIES FROM VIETNAM,
SOUTH AMERICA, AND YES, EVEN THE
UNITED STATES.
IN THE 1960s, CUBA ATTEMPTED
TO IMPORT NUCLEAR MISSILES FROM
THE FORMER SOVIET UNION, WHICH
BROUGHT THE WORLD TO THE BRINK
OF A NUCLEAR WAR.
MORE RECENTLY, CUBA'S CLOSE TIES
WITH RUSSIA, IRAN, VENEZUELA
CONTINUES TO CAUSE SECURITY
PROBLEMS FOR THIS COUNTRY, THE
UNITED STATES, ONE EXAMPLE,
2016, AMERICAN DIPLOMATS IN
HAVANA WERE REPORTEDLY ATTACKED
WITH MICROWAVE RADIATION FROM A
WEAPON SYSTEM.
GUESS WHAT, DEPLOYED BY RUSSIAN
TECHNOLOGY.
THIS KIND OF HOSTILE BEHAVIOR
FROM CUBA'S DICTATORSHIP FURTHER
ISOLATES THE SILENT NATION FROM
THE REST OF THE WORLD AND IT
DOES NOTHING TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THE GREAT PEOPLE OF
CUBA.
OF COURSE, WHILE MILLIONS GO
HUNGRY, THOSE IN POWER, THEY
NEVER MISS A MEAL.
AND STILL, AMID THE ONGOING
PROTESTS AND IN SPITE OF MANY
EFFORTS TO PREVENT THE WORLD
FROM SEEING WHAT IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING, CUBANS AREN'T CRYING
OUT FOR MORE FOOD, MEDICINE, AND
NO, JOE BIDEN, THEY ARE NOT CRYG
OUT FOR MORE COVERT VACCINES.
THEY ARE CRYING OUT FOR LIBERTY
AND FREEDOM.
AS AMERICANS, FREEDOMS WE OFTEN
TAKE FOR GRANTED.
THE FREEDOM OF PRESS, FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT, AND THE GOD-GIVEN
RIGHT TO PURSUE HAPPINESS.
WE BELIEVE IN AMERICA AND ARE
ENDOWED BY OUR CREATOR NATURAL
RIGHTS GRANTED BY GOD, ENDOWED
BY OUR CREATOR.
AND IF JOE BIDEN IS WATCHING,
NOT ENDOWED BY THE THING, YOU
KNOW THE THING, THE THING IS
GOD, THE CREATOR OF EVERYTHING,
JOE.
NOW, WE UNEQUIVOCALLY SUPPORT
THOSE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN
CUBA TONIGHT.
THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR LIVES AT
RISK.
THEY ARE SEEKING LIBERTY.
THEY ARE SEEKING FREEDOM.
WE ALL PRAY THAT THEY SUCCEED.
NOW, WE FREEDOM LOVING
AMERICANS, WE DO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE PEOPLE OF
CUBA, AS THEY ARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES THI